alors hier à 13 heures nous avions
accueilli l'un des représentants de
monsieur jim black monsieur farès qui
nous disait sa crainte face à l'élection
de béchir gemayel aujourd'hui avec nous
monsieur antoine basbous correspondant à
paris de la voix du liban d'une radio à
sensibilité chrétienne antoine vous
faites partie de ceux qui avaient
approuvé l'élection de béchir gemayel
alors pourquoi
tout simplement parce que l'élection de
bachir gemayel représente l'espoir pour
beaucoup de libanais c'est un nombre
fort cet angle de dialogue ce n'est pas
un homme de compromis
ce n'est pas un service bis mais cette
lentille serkis et c'est monsieur dans
le pays en avait besoin un grand besoin
il fallait trancher il fallait sauver et
avec lui j'espère que le sauvetage du
pays
sera à l'ordre du jour en face qu'on
peut parler d'élection vraiment
démocratique dans un pays où il y avait
quelque chose comme 80 mille soldats
israéliens il y avait également trente
mille soldats syriens trente mille
soldats palestiniens et j'imagine 60
sont dix mille soldats y là il est pays
soumis à un clip occupation et qui n'est
pas de fraîche date
7,7 au parlement élu il y a dix ans déjà
qui a élu béchir gemayel
les conditions ne sont pas parfaites
mais entre le vide constitutionnel et
l'élection dans ces conditions là dans
ces conditions là je préfère tout le
monde a préféré d'ailleurs que les
comptes que les élections aient lieu
mais quand on voit par exemple monsieur
begin qui envoie ses félicitations à
celui qu'il appelle mon cher ami gemayel
est ce que ça ne m'est pas béchir
gemayel dans l'embarras pour plus tard
notamment vis-à-vis du monde arabe
j'imagine que ça qu'on promet pas mal
le rôle de bachir gemayel cela dit
gemayel n'a jamais coupé avec le monde
arabe au contraire il a été reçu hier à
la demande des saoudiens en présence des
durs du monde arabe au mois de juin
maginot mode afin fin juillet à
l'entretien avait été assez froid et
paris au contraire vous profiterez je
n'ai pas des informations de première
main mais jamais on a dit que
l'entretien était fois d'ailleurs les
les les contacts entre gemayel et les
saoudiens n'ont pas cessé depuis et
depuis j'ai signé g
j'ai signalé qu'il y a eu deux
rencontres siro kata aides dont l'une
s'est passé s'est passé il ya pas
longtemps il ya quatre jours de cela
alors quand les israéliens sont arrivés
au liban ils ont dit qu'ils voulaient un
traité de paix avec israël béchir
gemayel lui serait plutôt opposés à la
signature d'un traité de paix avec
israël comment va-t-il arriver à votre
avis à se sortir de cette situation
le traité de paix est proposée au liban
tout entier béchir gemayel et le
président du liban mais il a il a
consulté la chambre il doit consulter le
gouvernement et en attendant il doit y
avoir une des élections j'imagine
j'imagine que dans deux ans le liban
devrait élire un nouveau gouvernement un
nouveau parlement et c'est ce sont les
institutions légales du liban qui en
décideront ne craignez pas une partition
du liban
ce que je crains c'est plutôt le
démembrement du pays et
qu'ils réel prennent par exemple le sud
du pays sous la couverture de bagdad que
la syrie garde une partie du pays dans
le nord et l'est du pays est entre ces
deux
parties occupées par son voisin
un petit état chrétien mais avec
l'élection de béchir gemayel s'est c'est
une éventualité qui n'a pas beaucoup de
chance wallah également d'une chaire
gemayel en train de réunifier l'armée
une armée qui est divisé et puis
également de faire entrer cette armée à
l'intérieur de beyrouth ouest pour
récupérer l'armement lourd que les
palestiniens sont en train paraît-il de
laisser à leurs alliés de la gauche
libanaise comment béchir gemayel petite
sphère l'armee elle existe
elle n'a pas elle n'a pas le tonus elle
n'a pas
une autorité on ne lui a rien demandé
et quand elles existent matériellement
on peut on peut
la lancée et elle existe également à à
beyrouth ouest il ya plusieurs casernes
à vélo touristes qui sont intactes les
militaires libanais sont humiliés à la
suite de 7 8 ans d'occupation ils
doivent présenter leurs papiers à tous
les barrages qu'ils soient tenus par des
miliciens palestiniens par les
israéliens par les palestiniens donc ces
gens là ils ont en leur esprit
je crois pouvoir dire un certaine
revanche ils doivent ils attendent
l'heure où un gouvernement fort dit
'descendez pris les choses en main ils
attendent 7,6 et une armée qui compte
maintenant 26 millions à laquelle on
ajoute toutes les milices du pays ça
fera dans les cinquante mille hommes
elle aura vraiment beaucoup de points à
condition que béchir gemayel réussissent
à réaliser l'unité du pays ce sera la
clé leurs solutions physiquement parlant
on peut pas parler de risques de
divisions pourquoi parce que ceux qui
parlent de division c'est du chantage
ils n'ont pas les moyens de leur de
leurs menaces enfin tous les députés ne
se sont pas rendus au parlement il ya
trente députés qui ont refusé d'y aller
mais il ya 62 qui sont présentés et qui
ont voté et qui ont élu public
je remercie quelques réactions tout
d'abord le président françois mitterrand
adressé un message nouveau président
libanais dans lequel ils l'assurent de
l'attachement de la france à la
souveraineté et à l'intégrité
territoriale et à l'indépendance
nationale du liban le chef de l'état
français forme des voeux pressant pour
que tous les libanais puissent se
rassembler dans la reconstruction d'un
état démocratique